Republicans are now bragging about
diversity
quite literally in a room full of white
people mostly white men this you you
just have to see it and I want to talk
about diversity in sort of a more
serious way and actually take the
question of diversity more seriously
Republicans have started to repeat lines
like this is one of the most diverse
Republican classes we've ever had
we have more women we have more this
that the other thing they thought they
had more Jewish people because they were
including George Santos and that turns
out that that was a lie and during the
event that they did yesterday with Fox
News propagandist Sean Hannity they
talked about this issue of diversity a
couple of times I'm going to play a
couple of clips for you here is Sean
Hannity saying he loves seeing more
diversity in the Republican party you
know uh congresswoman I know I've known
you a long time
um one of the things I'd like to see and
I'm seeing yeah is more diversity in the
Republican party to me the Democratic
party is the party of coastal
okay I think uh Elites Coastal Elites
yes and then Elise stefanic actually
talks about it and she does some of the
types of bragging we've heard for the
last few weeks from Republicans take a
look around at these wonderful members
this is the most diverse class of
Republicans ever elected in the history
of the United States Congress we have
more women than were ever elected before
more Hispanic members ever elected
before now as you see the camera panning
it's basically all white men in the room
for this very special Republican event I
guess I see three women in the
background someone pointed out that
there's one guy that maybe is Hispanic
but okay you get the point more Africa
African-American members in modern
history this shows that our party is
growing and I will tell you the America
First agenda is a growing big tent
agenda we've never done better than we
do today among Hispanic voters and
president Trump and House Republicans
were a huge part of doing that okay so
there's a few things that we have to
understand first of all when the initial
when they talk about we're doing better
than ever with a lot of these groups
when you start with such disastrous
numbers you really only have up as the
direction that you can go so I wouldn't
read too much into that but what these
Republicans very much expose is that for
them this issue of diversity is checking
a box it's perfunctory it's contrived
it's just something that they can say so
that they can argue hey we also have
different types of people here like the
Democrats do it's not organic it doesn't
stem from policy it comes from who can
we fleece because the entire movement is
a scam we exposed that two weeks ago you
can check out the segment modern
conservative autism is a scam
but the reality is that these aren't
just boxes that you check
the makeup
of political constituencies is a direct
reflection of the policies or the
perceived policies of those groups and
that's why this can very quickly become
a fraught debate first of all it's not
about we need the exact makeup in our
elected officials of the population at
large you can never really achieve that
because you can always say hey you know
what there's fifth the population is
50.3 percent women
so we should have 50.3 women in the
House of Representatives okay all right
well you could probably do that okay
here's the racial demographics of the
country they should be exactly
represented in the House of
Representatives okay maybe you could do
that all right here's the percentage of
the country that is immigrants that
should be exactly represented also the
percentage of people with a physical
disability should be rep sexual oriented
it's extraordinarily difficult to have a
perfect mirroring in our elected
officials of every demographic alignment
in the general population that's not
what this is about I don't believe
that's what the left is actually talking
about the important thing to know
is that voter demographics
that support political groups vary based
on a lot of different factors it can
depend on the candidates that are that
are running and how they appeal to
different groups of people it could
depend on what the most important issues
are when National Security and the
economy maybe are the issues being
emphasized you're going to see a
different demographic alignment than if
the issues are say abortion and
education just for picking certain ones
but what we see is that overwhelmingly
there is very little diversity in the
Republican party now I know Trump does
these events and he puts blacks for
Trump on the stage behind him and it's
all very uh uh uh stage managed for lack
of a better term but roughly speaking
somewhere between 89 and 93 percent of
black voters vote for Democrats 93
percent voted for Joe Biden based on
exit polls 78 percent of LGBT voters
voted for Biden 71 percent of Jewish
Americans identify as or lean towards
Democratic candidates 66 percent of
Hispanic or Latino voters voted for
Biden 66 of Asian American voters voted
for Biden 62 percent of naturalized
citizens uh people like me voted for Joe
Biden 60 of those 18 to 29 voted for Joe
Biden 59 of disabled voters voted for
Joe Biden 55 percent of women okay
you're getting closer and closer to 50
50. diversity isn't something you do to
get it on record where you go hey we got
some Jewish folks like George Santos oh
he's not Jewish all right cross him off
the list but we've still got more Latino
voters than we've had before it's a
reflection of policy it's a reflection
of policy the way the Republican party
goes about it is let's just see if we
can find people who check certain boxes
and convince them to vote for us rather
than let's develop a policy platform
that will naturally attract different
groups of Voters they're sort of going
like top down rather than building from
the bottom up and it's not clear whether
that will work as a long-term political
strategy their numbers have improved
slightly over the last couple of
election Cycles with some of these
groups but with others they continue to
be a disaster the way the Republican
Party sees this issue is just like a
product what kind of a product can we
build by adding people who check
different demographic boxes and as a
result they're really not doing well
with just about any of these groups the
the irony of course is as the room as
the camera pans it's all white people
and mostly white men which is really in
contrast to the words about diversity
that are coming out of their mouths